This one was pretty tricky. For the first one, we get the HTML and send request
for style.css and timing.js. So, we can rule out the inline option. Next, we
get timing.js and execute it and css
arrives afterwards. This tells me this must be
the async script, because if it weren't. We'd have to block and wait for CSS.
>> Great job! Next one?
>> Okay. So, we get the HTML.
Send request for style.css. I don't see
any request for JavaScript. But then, when we
finish loading the CSS we run the script. So, this must be the inline case.
>> Yup. Inline scripts, block, and CSS.
>> And, in this last one, we have
request for CSS and JavaScript, and JavaScript arrives first.
But then, we block and wait untill CSS
is available. So, this must be blocking script tag.